foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Rachel Cruz number
one best-selling author multiple times a
co-host of the popular afternoon smart
money happy hour I just assumed happy
hours were in the afternoon yeah so
check it out on podcast on the Ramsey
networks there and you can be part of
all of that and enjoy her she's with me
today my daughter answering your
questions at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Sean's in Los Angeles
hey Sean how are you
I'm doing well how about you better than
I deserve what's up
yeah I just had a quick question for you
guys
um so I'm a first-gen American immigrant
family grew up with a low middle income
and so I went through college debt free
I made sure to go on scholarship and
then I recently graduated and got a job
um and then the first year I made 180k
um I love it yeah where'd it go what are
you doing when you're out of college for
180k that's impressive
so my job required me to do a lot of
travel so you know I sold my car during
the peak of the pandemic to get now what
do you do for a living that makes 180k
oh I am an aerospace engineer oh I guess
you are way to go man amazing good for
you appreciate it I bet your mom and dad
are just sitting around smiling
yeah yeah yeah my son the genius
so yeah my main question was basically
um so I had to buy a new car so I came
back because I switched jobs
um and now that I'm in Los Angeles you
know I have I've been trying to max out
my retirements and everything and I
enjoy my job but it's kind of I grew up
in a situation where you know we made
sure to you know say what we can don't
buy anything unnecessary and recently
I've been kind of I had like a good
amount of wealth in the savings and
everything like that and my question is
more of how to kind of get past the idea
of you know scared to spend it and then
on top of that how to invest it properly
so that I don't spend too much and kind
of build a budget for myself for the
future yeah what where is your family
from Sean
uh we're based out of oh so my family's
from India originally India okay okay
that's great
um yeah you know I think when it comes
to the idea of giving your yourself
permission to spend
um it's always helpful for me Sean to
have something visual that I see with my
numbers so that would be a budget and
doing it knowing exactly where my
expenses where my money's going to know
that my bases are covered that I'm doing
quote unquote what I'm supposed to be
doing with money right so making sure
retirement's good we're saving for the
future all of that is done and when you
look at that and say okay and then I
have some left over and actually putting
it in line items and kind of like making
yourself forcing yourself to spend which
sounds kind of funny but uh when we talk
about money a lot it's almost like
building a muscle and spending is one of
those muscles that you you have to build
if you're not used to it or you're
scared and you have that kind of more
scarcity mentality it is very difficult
to enjoy your money and just to spend so
if you're in a position where you do
have that extra money every month I
would put it in a line item and again it
can be a small percentage you don't have
to do anything crazy uh but I would put
it in a line item and and make yourself
spend it again whether that's going to a
concert whether that's going out to eat
whether that's going on a trip like
whatever that looks like but uh
practicing spending and enjoying it
because that is part of living yeah and
being generous investing and spending
wisely these are the three things you
can do okay gotcha and spending wisely
is the enjoyment Factor so to speak
you'll find later as you go along that
generosity is actually more enjoyable
than all of it but
um anyway you need to be doing all three
at all times then when you're doing a
budget like Rachel's saying we have a uh
the world's best budgeting app that you
can use for free it's called every
dollar and the reason it's called every
dollar is every month you should give
every dollar
a name every dollar a mission every
dollar an assignment and here's what's
interesting once you're doing that
very few people mess up
because we do stupid stuff when we don't
see it in perspective to the other
things like oh I can afford that oh wait
I can't buy groceries you know but if
you got groceries down beside it you go
oh I can't afford that but if you buy a
couch and you go well uh
and I've still got money to do all the
other stuff and it was allocated with
one of the dollar line items like Rachel
was saying then there's no guilt for
buying the couch because you didn't not
pay your rent because you bought a couch
but but when you just go oh I'm gonna
buy a couch on impulse it's not in
person it's not the perspective of the
holistic perspective of your whole
picture that the budget gives you that's
when people make mistakes but very few
people do stupid stuff on purpose
you know right like we're going to write
down and plan to do stupid stuff that
people don't do that so that's why the
budget fixes that for you
it'll cause you to to be careful in all
of it in generosity in spending and in
investing into a very very intentional
and then of course we're going to tell
you to take the free money that you can
find in that budget and work up what we
call the baby steps which is the
shortest fastest right way to become
wealthy
because I you know after
my money on getting in your car and I
didn't take any any loans because the
idea of having to owe someone a good
remote any form is kind of paranoia for
me good
um so I carry about 70k and just in my
as an emergency plan I know I don't need
that much
um and I know I can invest about 40K of
that yeah then we'll have plenty of left
over didn't do
um so I guess investing portion wise do
you guys have any recommendations as far
as how to make sure whether that's
passive or or kind of opportunities in
the stock market or other ways to I
guess further my wealth tell you what
I'm going to send you a copy of the book
The Total Money Makeover which is going
to walk you right up the baby steps what
to do first what to do second when you
get to what's called baby step four
you'll start putting 15 this is the
first time you invest you'll start
putting 15 of your income into
retirement savings Roth IRAs and 401ks
and good growth stock mutual funds so
hang on we'll have Austin the team pick
up and send you a Total Money Makeover
book it's the it's the baby steps on
steroids it'll show you every little
thing on what to do with the baby steps
Sam is with us in Boston hey Sam how are
you
I'm doing amazing how are you doing Dave
better than I deserve how can we help
yeah so I'm calling in um I got a career
question for you guys I recently uh just
moved into baby step three and just got
engaged which is super exciting
um so I'm calling because I currently
I'm I work as a assistant project
manager for uh infrastructure company
and I travel from for work
um I live in Upstate New Hampshire so
kind of outside of Boston by just a
couple of hours
um I live in a small town up in the
White Mountains
um but I'm calling because I'm kind of
struggling uh being you know newly
engaged and everything uh eventually I I
don't want traveling to be a long term
how much do you travel
um so I'm out on the road every week
right now for example five days a week
uh yeah it depends on on the week and
what's going on with the project but I'm
fortunate to be able to go home on
weekends yeah sounds like you're
changing jobs
it's pretty simple not a sustainable
lifestyle with the family not what you
want to do it's not you don't want to be
gone five days a week you said
and I don't think they're going to stop
you from doing that because they need
you to go do that that's why they hired
you
sorry to cut you short but it is pretty
that's pretty much that simple
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back either one
their watch and guarantee and shipping
is always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Justin
is in Austin Texas hi Justin welcome to
the Ramsay show
thank you for having me it's an honor to
be on certainly how can we help
I'd be kind of what would Dave do
question
um
my wife is looking to leave education
and go back to get her master's become a
therapist and so I'm looking for the
best way to approach to cash flow this
and not take out any debt we currently
make about 200 000 a year the only debt
we have is our home and one rental which
we are aggressively paying off and
trying to get paid off in the next three
years and so my big question is should I
suspend retirement knowing I get a
generous match from my employer uh to
help cash flow this or just tighten up
the budget and curious what you would do
um so a master's in counseling
correct okay to do what
to be a therapist to counsel uh families
adolescents
um you know families in need those kind
of things okay
um so as you're probably already aware
there is a vast Spectrum
of potential cost on this
you can spend we can spend a lot or a
little
and we already have the cost so I know
exactly how much does it cost me per
month how much is it going to cost you
right about 1400 and that's the exact
amount before tax if I was to pause my
retirement that I'd be getting each
month yeah when you said your household
income those 200.
correct
why can't you just cash flow 1400 and
keep doing your retirement
and that's what we're thinking about
doing we just didn't know if it'd be
wise to suspend knowing that she could
potentially come out of this making you
know right around 80 to 100K a year and
then that would just make things not so
tight so again I don't want to sacrifice
a retirement but if I had to I'm willing
to I just again want to make sure I'm
making the right decision yeah it would
be more sacrificing lifestyle Justin
than retirement is what is what we would
probably pick
um and and is it a two-year program
uh minimum two-year could be two and a
half ish depending on her uh internships
yeah gotcha and how old are you guys
I'm 38 she's 34. okay
yeah I mean I would continue to probably
just do retirements
um
yeah I would and then sacrifice
lifestyle I mean I know it makes it kind
of tight and I don't know if even
there's a extra work you could pick up
just as a side hustle you know every
other week for a little bit just to
bring in some extra cash you could do
that as well does she quit while she's
doing this
so she's gonna have the first year when
she's just doing classes she's going to
work part-time so that will help offset
a little bit of the cost but then as she
goes into her clinicals or internships
that will increase where she might so
when all of that happens what's the
household income
income is well the 200 is not
oh so you make 200. okay correct yeah
that's great then because if she's
working part-time a little bit next year
then that's going to give you guys some
breathing room and then it's really only
a year
maybe a few months of it being really
focused on just cutting some lifestyle
if you need to she makes 15 000 a year
she cash flowed it
correct yeah which is what we're going
to try to do just we're not sure the
workload just yet but ideally we would
like to not sacrifice at retirement if
we didn't have to I don't think you have
to I think you have to sacrifice
something else
but you make 200 you need fifteen
thousand I agree yeah I think I think
you cut I think you don't go on vacation
because we have a greater goal I think
we back Christmas down because you have
a greater goal I think we quit going out
to eat sadad gum much because you have a
greater goal or whatever your lifestyle
whatever you whatever you want to lump
into the lifestyle category what Rachel
was saying is dead on yeah it's this is
a lifestyle cut uh and again it's
temporary for a greater goal and it's a
wonderful greater goal I mean what she's
going into is good uh what you're paying
for it is a reasonable amount I mean
she's going to get this degree in the 30
35 000 range
um and you know be helping people this
is this is a good move this is this is
education the way it's supposed to be
used
uh to actually cause you to make more
and do good
you know that's what education is for as
opposed to getting a degree in
left-handed puppetry which some people
do and this kind of stuff so yeah that
that's this is very very good all
everything you brought to us was wise
except you guys just haven't looked at
we need to scale back lifestyle
and keep on our investment goals yep
that's what I would do so uh good
question thanks for calling Tommy is in
Augusta Georgia hey Tommy what's up
hey Dave wow I'm so happy I got through
to you
we're happy you're here Tommy can we
help
hey um I I've been listening to the
podcast every day
um
uh for maybe a month and a half I uh so
many so much of your stuff uh just makes
a whole lot of financial sense to me and
and I want to I admire the fact that you
guys bring Christ
onto the radio every single day and you
guys are not ashamed about the of the
Gospel no thank you Tommy how can we
help you today
I have
uh I'm getting married
yay I'm
I'm 52 years old I've never been married
and
I'm a little I'm a little anxious but
I'm very excited
uh my fiance and I
uh but between the two of us
um
well I'll just talk about my debt right
now um I have about 18 18 500 in student
loan debt
uh
probably another
uh 3000 and a furniture furniture debt
and
I also have
um
I have my my mortgage uh
90 98 000. so
when we get married I will be moving uh
to her house that she has and will be
telling mine
um the market value right now I believe
on mine is a roughly 165 so I think I'm
going to come out a little ahead
and I also
have
uh twenty thousand dollars in a high
yield savings account right now
I am
I've been reluctant to pay off this
student loan debt all because of this uh
this uh wish wishful thinking that
they're going to forgive it
um but I also understand that I received
that money as a loan years ago Tommy how
can we best help you today
I've
I'm just trying to uh
I don't I'm I guess I'm com uh where to
start I just don't know I just don't
know enough yet
um okay about what you guys are teaching
I'm very interested in it and I would
like to I've been telling my fiance
about it and
and the little bit that I know that I'm
you know telling her about
I don't know if if it's really clear if
I'm getting through clear to her okay so
Tommy what we're gonna do first and
foremost is Austin's gonna pick up and
we're gonna gift you and your fiancee
who will be your wife in two weeks our
wedding gift a wedding gift so so
congratulations Tommy you get a wedding
and Financial Peace University coming up
and so you go through that together so
you guys can at least be talking out of
the same you know with the same language
out of the same perspective but what
you're gonna do Tommy yeah is I would
take that money that in the high yield
savings account pay off the furniture
first get rid of that three thousand
dollar loan and then start tackling the
student loan debt and the Beautiful
Thing is Tommy when you guys sell your
home you're going to come out with about
65 000 and if she has any debt then
you're going to use some of that money
to pay off hers you guys together are
going to combine your finances you're
going to look at all of your debt
together lined up regardless of whose
debt it is and start working a plan to
pay that off you guys are going to
combine incomes you're gonna be
budgeting together so that's really the
first big step and then get an emergency
fund then you'll go on to Baby Steps
four five and six but you'll you're
going to dive deep into all of that with
Financial Peace University so I I would
sit down and you guys go through that
together because that that is the plan
and working together is a really key
part of this and I know all this is you
know new to you maybe even new to her
um of just this idea of being
intentional with your money and so I
think it's kind of a fun thing for you
Tommy that you're entering a new season
of Life as a married man for the first
time and there's probably this level of
feeling like other changes are gonna
happen your money is probably going to
look a lot different a year from now
which is very exciting because you may
actually end up controlling it and
feeling in control of it for the first
time ever so hang on the line Tommy
Austin will pick up
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you're here we love to give away money
around here I know that sounds weird a
place that is all about helping you with
your money we give money away and we're
giving away 500 a week this month and a
three thousand dollar grand prize in the
Ramsay cash giveaway no purchase
necessary you can enter up to once a day
must be 18 years older older and there's
great deals in the ramsesolutions.com
bookstore and all the books just about
all of them are best sellers and just
about all of them are ten dollars right
now and that includes the uh questions
for humans cards by uh Second Edition
the conversation cards out with Dr John
deloney so there's all kinds of things
there so be sure you check all this out
ten dollar sale and 500 a week at three
thousand dollar total grand prize
giveaway all available at
ramsesolutions.com
slash store John is in Dallas hey John
welcome to the Ramsey Show
it's an absolute pleasure speaking with
you guys today you too what's up
so I um uh my employer offers an
employee stock purchase plan at a 15
discount and
um I'm the type of guy that buys and
buys and buys and buys stocks and just
holds and holds forever and should I
when it comes to Employee Stock purchase
plan should I buy it and then wait for a
year for long-term capital gains and
sell it or should I buy it and sell it
right away what would be the strategy
for that
well I generally don't recommend you buy
it at all uh if you're going to buy it
don't let it become more than 10 percent
of your net worth uh single stocks are
much too risky and the 15 discount is
nothing special every single company
that has an employee stock option plan
has a 15 discount they're all set up
that way and so
um and if you'll pull up your 52-week
charts on the stock unless it's a very
unusual stock you'll see as much as 15
variance during the 52 weeks so in other
words you could lose anything the
discount is in one move of the stock and
so it's not like it's a huge discount 50
discount would be huge 15 percent in the
single stock as volatile as they are not
that big a deal so if you love your
company and your company has a great
track record and the stock looks like a
great stock to buy and you're just
absolutely chomping at the bit to do it
don't allow single stocks as a category
to become more than 10 percent of your
total net worth John I don't buy any
single stocks I don't own them one yeah
and there's I feel like a lot of
employees because we get this question
on the regular I feel like
um because I feel like for some people
too they if they have a good work
experience and they love their company
and they believe it talks good no I know
but that's what I'm saying is like it's
a there's an emotional tie for people
with work as well when this comes into
play so you do want to if that becomes
uh if those two Collide you want to
detach the emotion from it but I mean
I've talked to people and they're like I
just love my company so much it's just
so great and I'm going to be here for it
and I just believe in it it's like it's
a more of an emotional yeah type of
investment really bad idea yeah but the
thing the lack of diversification is
what we're talking about here when
you've got all your eggs in one basket
some fool is twirling the basket you
know and that's that's the old uh
financial planning thing the first time
I ran into this early like 25 years ago
I was sitting one-on-one doing a
coaching session with a lady who was 70
years old and she had her work for
Procter Gamble for 40 years and she had
all of her 401k and all of her wealth
780 000 in Procter Gamble stock well I
don't remember what happened I don't
even remember what year it was but that
year Procter Gamble had some crisis and
they lost 38 of their value and so her
780 000 turned into like 400 yeah and
she was freaking out but the reason was
she had left herself vulnerable that's a
high risk play because you're you bet
the farm you went up to the booth at the
Kentucky Derby and you bet the family
farm on one horse
and then somebody shoots the horse I
mean you know this oh my gosh well I
mean this is what happens right this is
the kind of garbage you get into before
the horse didn't win I know well it
could be just that simple but yeah it'd
be more dramatic if you did it my way
but the uh I mean this is what happens
in these companies right yeah totally I
mean it's just you lose your mind I'm
now in the George camel camp now I've
not got the horse haters after me but I
wasn't killing horses it was a bad
metaphor okay oh my gosh Booth is in the
floor laughing my kids love Spirits the
the cartoon it's great we love horses
here yes yes
anyway don't put all of your eggs in one
basket don't bet the farm on one horse
don't have a large portion of your net
worth any more than 10 percent in single
stocks tons of research projects like
hundreds of them that will show you that
individuals buying individual stocks
thinking they know what they're doing
lose money more often than they make
money and on average only make about a
seven percent rate of return on their
portfolio because they don't know what
the flip they're doing they're not
Diversified and it's a bad idea so I
only buy mutual funds for that reason
and I know a lot about it I mean I could
I can I know how to pick a stock and it
wouldn't be based on the fact that I
like the color of the company that was
on the sign or some kind of crap that
people do all the time so I mean you
know none of that it's we're going to
get into the actual financials on it but
all of that to say I don't want to make
a seven percent red return because I've
made over 12 percent by people who pick
stocks for a living all day long for a
billion dollar mutual fund they're
smarter than me yeah and they're more
specialized and they spend their whole
life on every little Nuance of that well
and what's interesting today and because
of apps technology and just the ability
for the average person to jump in
to the market well I mean stuff like
Robin Hood is an easier if there's an
easier access point so people are doing
it more and more because it's accessible
I mean like you can just it's right
there is acting like they have
democratized trading no you didn't
you're just an app where people can buy
stocks and do stupid butt stuff and they
do it all the time that's all it is and
that's how you got into the GameStop
thing right that's how you got into all
this other so what I'm saying is the
average consumer back in the 80s it was
a it was a day Traders yeah it was a
much it was a it was a whole thing we
had computers
and we could connect and we could yes
barely internet though yeah and we could
buy stuff and do stock trades I had a
friend that was a stock Trader that's
what he did for a living he lost 78 of
his money in one year yeah it was just
dumber than a rock you know I mean it's
just this is I've seen it over and over
and over and over again so all that to
say John not saying you're dumb and I'm
not saying what she's doing horrible I'm
just giving you some guidelines and the
reasons behind them don't do more than
10 of your total net worth in a stock
pick the stock for the right reasons 15
discount is not much those are our
comments on your questions so really
really good thing to think about so it
even says it in the Bible spread your
portions to seven yes to eight for
disaster may come upon the land or the
horse
the poor disaster could come you know
disaster could come sad about that poor
horse and so yeah but the
metaphorical horse yeah don't bet the
family farm at the racetrack on One race
and that's essentially what you're doing
right because you got all your net worth
tied up in a single play
and versus a mutual fund which is 90 to
200 different stocks in there so that's
the safety of it that's where yeah
they're spreading out of your money
spread your money around that's
diversification you hear Financial
people say I have a well-diversified
well that's all that means you spread
your money around money is like manure
it makes more when you spread it
you know doesn't you left in one pile
stinks spread it out grow stuff that's
how it works so same exact thing and uh
just keep it keep it you know keep it
simple don't try to be fancy and you'll
always make more money people you'll
always make more money in the Long Haul
there's the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality
is my co-host today number one
best-selling author KC is in New York
City hi Casey how are you
hey Dave I'm good how are you better
than I deserve what's up
um so I'm kind of a newer listener and
uh before I actually found you I had
filed bankruptcy and
um my current bank they offer a it's
kind of like a loan but it's not an
actual loan to help you rebuild your
credit um and what you do is
um you make payments every month to them
and they turn it in as you've made on
Time payments and then at the end you
actually get what you put into it
and they were telling me that uh with me
wanting to buy a house within the next
two years that that would be something
that I should do because the bankruptcy
would follow me for so long and I was
just kind of wanting to get your opinion
on it
so you filed a Chapter 7 bankruptcy a
total bankruptcy
yes wiped out all the bills
yes sir okay what happened
um so to be quite honest
um
I am in recovery
um I was a addict uh pretty much my
entire life how old are you and I had a
lot of things
um I'm 38. what were you on
uh heroin how long you been dry
uh two years congratulations congrats
proud of you mm-hmm thank you okay
all right and how and what was the size
of the bankruptcy how much debt did you
have
uh
all total it was about uh 68 000. okay
all right well KC in 1988 I filed
bankruptcy my wife Sharon and I lost
everything
because I was stupid and um I went too
far in debt
one of the conclusions I came to
uh coming out of that bankruptcy and as
you said you're kind of new to our stuff
was that I want to avoid debt
I hate that
if you look up Dave Ramsey on the
internet about the first thing you're
going to see is he hates debt
you know right after somebody's pissed
off at me about something but somewhere
around in there I'll have Dave hates
debt right you follow me yes sir and the
reason the reason is is that
um obviously it didn't land well for me
didn't land well for you
um and uh you know it landed us in a
mess it did it was not a blessing to us
and so uh and your most powerful wealth
building tool going forward is your debt
is your income staying out of debt and
I'll give you this I I haven't seen the
statistics in a while and I wish Dr John
deloney was here he could probably quote
one for me but the recidivism rate in
other words staying sober
versus not staying sober
has a lot to do with controlling your
life and keeping it very clean peaceful
and simple would you agree with that
yes sir as opposed to hectic out of
control chaotic uh all those kinds of
things debt is all of those things
it's hectic it's chaotic it's you're no
longer in control of your money it has
to go to someone else and all that kind
of stuff so I'm making a case here for
you to consider that part of your
sobriety even is connected to your
continued sobriety is is connected to
keeping your life real clean real simple
and that's no debt so I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to sell you as hard as I can
and you staying away from debt now once
we've done that then we say okay why
would I need to rebuild my credit
because the credit rebuild thing is a
joke it's all about uh I need credit why
so I can go into debt why so I can get
credit why so I can go into debt why so
I can get credit why so I can go into
debt well I mean it's a dog chasing its
tail this whole I'm going to build my
credit thing can you get a house after
filing Chapter 7 bankruptcy in two years
using this Bank program I doubt it I
think they lied to you or they don't
know what they're talking about I don
don't think you're going to get approved
in 24 months from a discharge date on a
chapter seven for a traditional mortgage
I think you might 36 months or 48 months
later get approved for a mortgage with
absolutely no credit at all after your
Chapter 7 bankruptcy a Chapter 7
bankruptcy stays on your credit bureau
report for 10 years it does not count
against you for purposes of a mortgage
but three to four years I don't think
you're going to get a mortgage in two
years no matter what you do unless you
get a subprime rip-off mortgage from
this bank that's teasing you with this I
would stay away from those people Casey
okay
you're following all this that makes
sense yes sir that makes sense cool
how's your family
uh we are all back together now and uh
doing
doing fine back together with your wife
or what
uh my wife and my children wow that's
awesome how many children have you got
uh three okay I want you to get a house
I don't want the house to get you and I
don't want you to step into a trap
pursuing a house too aggressively
that's right that's what we're trying to
avoid renting KC renting is not bad in
your case you're okay just rent for a
little while we're putting our life back
together after a traumatic life
experience and dude let me just tell you
we work with addicts all the time
because a hundred percent of addicts
have financial problems eventually
so we I've worked with addicts for 30
years and if you beat heroin you are
what's known as an unbelievably
courageous strong guy
that is a tough one you've been dry two
years you're amazing
you hang on I really appreciate it yeah
you play through you you're fighting a
big dragon and you can win you're the
guy that can do it but man I'm telling
you you're you're a beast you get it we
want to help we want to be part of your
recovery we're going to put you and your
wife through Financial Peace University
free
and you guys go learn how to handle
money and become absolutely not joking
at all man we love people like you
thank you
yeah you go get that stuff and we'll get
we'll get you into a house the right way
man yeah and not let that house get you
and you stay away from Banks you can't
trust them
if you can tell their line if their
Mouse move than most of them yeah and if
it seems too good to be true a few good
Bankers out there but good gracious the
rest of you people
if it sounds too good to be true then
they know and they're probably feeding
on exactly what they're know that you
want which is a house so they're gonna
create a formula do something in order
to convince you to stay with them so you
know yeah I would say Casey Dave said it
earlier but truly I'm like just
you guys rebuilding your family after
this and slowing down renting not making
like massive big decisions right getting
a steady income you guys budgeting
together start saving you know there's
there's just a beauty in rebuilding this
and it's going to take time and it's
going to be it's going to be a slower
process but that's actually I think the
wisest way to do it and so that includes
something like a purchase of a house
yeah
file bankruptcy in 1988 a banker told me
go sign up for every Financial magazine
subscribe to Money Magazine Forbes
anything like that and I did and within
five months I was getting pre-approved
credit cards
we had decided not to borrow money so we
just chopped them up but I mean that's
how dumb the system is and how dumb a
banker is okay you just filed chapter
seven bankruptcy on millions of dollars
worth of real estate because you're an
idiot so the first thing you do is go
sign up for a whole bunch of financial
magazines so you can get pre-approved
credit cards to really prove you're an
idiot this is this was me okay I mean
this is like how dumb can you be but
there's always somebody watching of
course he wants you in it it's always
somebody wants to build your credit yeah
just shoot me oh my gosh just build my
credit yeah why so I can get into debt
why so I can build my credit why so I
can get into debt
and then we worship at the altar of the
great FICO great FICO you bring us
offerings we bring you offerings so you
can be provide our provider you bring us
good things of great FICO we get good
things because we have big FICO everyone
wants big FICO how dumb are we man you
people have lost your minds out there
and I was I used to be captain of you
now I'm not this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
number one best-selling author co-host
of smart money happy hour a very new
popular new podcast with George Campbell
here on the Ramsay networks is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Tyler
is going to start this hour off in
Austin Texas hey Tyler how are you
hey I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
hey I was calling uh so my wife and I
were on baby steps four five and six and
we are
thinking about building like an Adu a
little additional dwelling in our
backyard
um and you know just something small to
add some square footage to allow for
people to stay when family comes and
visits
um maybe a little homeschooling area and
then from time to time we might Airbnb
it out
um but I'm looking at doing that and was
thinking about taking out a home equity
loan for that instead of
moving up in house right instead of
selling your house and just getting more
square footage and because we're kind of
getting to that point
um we owe like 150 right now on our
mortgage so I like where that's at and I
really don't want to move in-house but
I'm I'm just having a hard time kind of
justifying that home equity loan but it
also seems like it might be logical
how much will the Edition be Tyler have
you guys priced anything out well we're
thinking around 75 000. okay how much
you guys make a year
about a hundred okay
yeah well we'll never you know be in the
business to tell you to take a HELOC out
to to do any type of renovation or
addition on your home anything ever so
to be able to save up and just cash flow
this thing uh is what yeah the next
option would well to me like you're
about to over build your neighborhood
not really I mean I I'm a realtor as
well in the area
um so I mean you know it should add
about a hundred thousand dollars worth
of value to our neighborhood no you feel
their properties in the neighborhood to
have that so your house is worth what
now
350. okay and 450 000 customers always
come on your street
yeah the last couple properties I sold
were right at 400 without uh an Adu 400
yeah who you're about to be at the top
of or over build your neighborhood with
a weird part with a weird type of square
footage
the square footage that you're adding
has to be used for particular uses
versus a home of actual square footage I
wouldn't do this from a real estate
perspective
okay you said you're a realtor have you
ever shown a house with a mother-in-law
apartment to people that didn't have a
mother-in-law wanted to live in it
yeah yeah I do it's difficult I looked I
looked at one not long ago I considered
it and we ruled it out because we were
being charged price per square foot to
include the mother-in-law apartment and
we're aimed to dream up how I turn it
into a gun closet or something
sure you know I just it didn't have good
use right
so it's just because I I guarantee you
my mother-in-law's not moving in there
so that you know that's uh you know I I
and I'm not definitely not running an
Airbnb next door to me no I don't think
it's good square footage I don't think
it's a good investment and I wouldn't
use a HELOC so I got about 73 reasons
why I would not do this deal I think
you're jonesing for some extra square
footage for your growing family yeah I
would look at it and I think that's a
reasonable move and maybe moving up in
house as long as the house payment is no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed and move up in
neighborhood move up in square footage
move up in house I'm not going to be in
the top of the neighborhood with weird
square footage
newer builds I feel like and I guess
depending on where you are in the
country but I feel like even ones that
we walked through you know a few years
ago the layout for families you know is
different is different than it was you
know in 2010 so I'm like so you can get
maybe even what you want the new plans
are much better yeah so Tyler I feel
like you guys as a family you talked
about homeschool area you even an extra
area for guests like the way that that
houses now are laid out I feel like you
guys could maybe get everything that you
want by just moving up and home versus
having to do this whole construction
thing and and I'll be honest too I think
some of it I would I would be as
realistic as possible Tyler because if
nobody is in that the the percentage of
you guys actually airbn being it out is
probably below like if you have kids and
life is going on you know so like even
the way that you guys are thinking about
it are there ways that another part or
another type of home could scratch that
itch another way versus building out
this whole other part of your house
Chris is in Idaho Falls Idaho hi Chris
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for having my call today
sure how can we help
so basically
I have a 401k from a previous employer
and it's just kind of sitting there the
career I'm at now doesn't offer the same
benefits before and so it's kind of just
been sitting for like the last six
months or so and I'm not sure what I
should do with it a hundred percent of
the time that you leave a company uh we
recommend you take your 401K with you by
Rolling it in a direct transfer rollover
into a traditional IRA picking out good
Mutual Funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and International four
categories evenly spaced and do a direct
transfer rollover to help you do every
bit of that click smart Vester at
ramseysolutions.com find the Brokers and
uh
Financial folk in your area that we
recommend that have the heart of a
teacher and we'll walk you through that
but we take it with you and here's the
reasons we take it with you you can
choose from Mutual Funds all over 8 000
mutual funds in the open market for your
IRA in your old 401K you're stuck with a
12 or 8 or whatever number of options
you had at the old company so you have
more options to pick better funds you
more control over it and you don't
forget to manage it when it's laying
back there in some place in the past
people forget to look at it and so those
are the three reasons we tell you to
take take it with you always direct
transfer means you fill out the
paperwork the money goes straight into
there you do not take a check from the
old place if they send you a check they
have to withhold twenty percent and you
don't have a hundred percent to do the
rollover and you're going to end up
paying taxes on that other 20. is you
don't have that other 20 so do a hundred
percent rollover direct transfer goes
directly from your old company into the
IRA does not come to you get a smart
investor Pro to help you pick all that
out and get it working
it just gives you a lot more control yes
and this is a very common thing right
now I mean the amount of people
switching jobs and changing companies
and everything is it feels like an
all-time high uh it's so much so for a
lot of you out there listening and you
have and if you have left go back and
get that 401k if you didn't take it with
you
um because yeah it's it it when it's
front of Minds like you said being able
to manage it and actually look at it and
feel emotion towards it and to know what
to do talking to a professional all of
it it's yours right it's not just
hanging back there in the past where
your employer just keeps it exactly
exactly and don't roll it to your new
employer
if they do have a 401k because again
limited options less control you've got
total control this way there's no point
in keeping it at the old place and no
point in rolling into the new place
so really good question Chris I'm glad
you called us thank you this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today safe
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
when we started this whole thing called
Ramsey
the Dave Ramsey show was called the
money game and I had a co-host back in
the day had two co-hosts back in the day
now I've got a bunch of co-hosts
different ones obviously but when we
started this thing the whole idea was
learning how to handle money
with common sense today we talk about
careers and mental health with common
sense as well relationships with common
sense with Dr Dr D Dr John deloney and
Ken Coleman but the whole money thing
was about how to handle money well to
get control of our lives and become
outrageously generous and wealthy and
change our family tree
that has over 30 years
we've ended up spending an inordinate
amount of energy towards that end to
become wealthy and generous to get
people out of debt because that's the
biggest blocker
for them to become outrageously wealthy
and outrageously generous if you get out
of debt your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income if you
invest a hundred dollars a month from
age 25 to age 65 in a decent growth
stock mutual fund it will be one million
176 thousand dollars you retire a
millionaire 25 to 65. but you can't have
a 750 F-150 payment
you can't have a student loan that's
been around so long you think it's a pet
a Master Card American distress or
discovered bondage
you can't just keep yourself in payments
where all you do is work for the man all
you do is work for these stinking banks
that have better furniture and bigger
buildings than you do the reason is you
gave them all your stinking money
and you have no money because you gave
it all of them and that has been what
we've become known for because it's the
single largest blocker for folks out
there and debt has been so normalized in
our culture that to even imagine living
without it is unbelievable
and uh article just handed To Us by our
producer yesterday the New York fed
released its q1 report on household debt
includes a record high
trillion dollar
Consumer Debt balance in America today
so I'm we're doing no good
because I mean we're not even making a
dent
apparently we're going to be in business
forever
this is for 17. job security trillion
dollars with persistent credit card debt
and Rising delinquency rates
that's where we're at and it's it's wild
that it says in here a typical first
quarter sees credit card balances
decline as people pay off what they
spend over the holidays while trying to
out gift their in-laws but for the first
time ever the New York fed stated that
tracking this for 20 years this isn't
the case this year so for the first time
instead balances remained flat over q1
suggesting that people aren't cutting
back and are probably using credit cards
to finance daily spending due to the
right to the rising cost of pretty much
everything
and so
it and I feel like
this is where when the inflation
conversation started about 18 months ago
here on this show
the fear was that people were going to
more than ever
justify take that margin that was there
and now isn't there and continue to live
a lifestyle and make up that difference
with credit cards yeah but let's be real
clear here the debt is not because of
inflation the debt is because you're
wussed out and refused to cut your
freaking lifestyle to offset inflation
because you're still sitting in a line
of 30 cars to buy an unbelievably
expensive cup of coffee
and yet I'm in debt because of inflation
now you're in debt because you didn't
cut your spending when inflation hit you
yeah that's why you're in debt so this
is not an outside variable that is
controlling your life it's you not
controlling the variables in your life
and so your butt ends up in yeah and
what sucks is you know for a lot of
people though it's not this outrageous
lifestyle that they're living you know
that there's two incomes they have kids
they have family like they are living
life the quote-unquote American standard
of living that again you can we can
argue the standard of living of what it
is but
what's difficult is when you have to go
backwards nobody likes to go backwards
that's why that's why sacrificing feel
outrageous because it felt normal that's
yes and so when you actually
consider the way we all live yes it's
outrageous white crazy styles are
outrageous well you look at the standard
you know the the square the average
square footage can I can I can I can I
get a virgin I don't know can you well
barely barely but no but you look at the
average square footage in the 70s now
average car average vacations I mean you
look at all of it and it has the
American lifestyle has gone up and so
our expectations on what is normal is
here and so for families that are living
paycheck to paycheck that are doing this
and sure because you know you have a 600
car loan like there there is still debt
in the picture that is causing less
margin but when something like inflation
hits and eggs and bacon everything goes
up in your grocery bill is like what and
to fill up your car you're looking at
the gas you're like what that stuff in
in the moment like that does hurt
because there's not the margin for that
extra hundred extra 200 extra 300 that
now is going out on normal expenses so
so to cut back which I agree with you
but it feels like but I what am I
supposed to cut back to because because
normalized where I'm where I am no
normalized outrageous yes we've become
exp we became uh entitled to outrageous
and so I'm entitled to this and and so
you know inflation then forced me
to go into that which is absolutely
hogwash you just did not I mean all it
is is you have to address you have to
look in the mirror and go we just buy
some really stupid stuff I mean we
really buy some stupid stuff well most
people in most countries could exist for
a year off of the crap that's in your
garage that you've not even seen in a
year
you know I mean we buy some stupid stuff
so yes it's normalized it doesn't feel
outrageous but it is outrageous so I I
always resist when Bank rates senior
industry and analyst says uh suggesting
that people aren't cutting back and
using credit cards is it's because of
the rising cost of inflation no they're
not cutting back to offset inflation
duper that's what's really going on and
so you know and I get it I it's not fair
I don't like inflation I don't want that
to take your check away from you but
don't be a victim you're not a victim
you're a victim of the person in your
mirror and the idea here's here's
another plan if you think getting into
debt to maintain your lifestyle is going
to maintain your lifestyle there's an
end to that there's a mathematical into
that it eventually comes it's a
boomerang comes back around smacks you
in the head and says hey dummy yeah
family's out there though because I mean
I was sitting down with a family they
made 80 000 and you look at you look at
month to month after taxes you know and
you're looking you're like okay like
everything on their budget was not
unreasonable right I'm like it's an hour
current it's a family of five and it's
like yeah this is what a Costco this is
what it takes to feed the family this is
what you know granted the kids are doing
a sport like I mean like it's life it's
just it is life and life is expensive
and so families out there that are
listening it's like if you when you're
feeling that pressure that you felt even
before inflation and then add some of
this on here where life got even more
expensive you have to evaluate needs
versus wants and this is where we've
Blended so much that our what we want
has become a need and so being able to
prioritize and really look
and it's and it's hard but it's like
okay what really are our needs and we
talk about the four walls food shelter
utilities and transportation and then
under that there has to be a priority
because in order for you to sleep at
night and to actually have peace and
control your money is so much worth it
than some of this other stuff that's in
your budget and so cutting some of that
for the time being is probably a reality
to help you get on the other side of
this it doesn't have to be forever but
depending on the credit card and and
functioning in that cycle of I'll just
use the credit card to to offset the
stuff it gets you into more trouble and
less peace you're killing yourself yep
killing yourself that is not your answer
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here if you
haven't heard over 10 million people
have now gone through Financial Peace
University
it is the most concise clear way
execute the wealth building steps that
we have proven not only getting out of
debt and getting on a budget but
learning about insurance learning about
real estate executing on all the
different pieces and nuances of what we
teach and you hear your bits and pieces
of it here on the radio sometimes you
see a YouTube clip and well Dave I can
get all your stuff out there for free
you could have got it all for free
before I did it it's called common sense
but the point is the best thing we do
around here with money is Financial
Peace University and we show you very
clearly how to not only what the lessons
are the nine lessons but we also are
going to walk with you with a
coordinator someone to be in Virtual or
in person with you and a group of people
to hold you accountable and to encourage
you when you're scared and struggling
and uh we're doing Financial Peace
University right now with coordinators
on on Virtual in addition to thousands
of locations right this second and all
the Ramsay personalities are
coordinating Rachel your class is shut
off because you're like in the week
three right I know I just had my class
right before came on the air with you oh
yeah today so yeah we are we just
finished Lesson Four no you're halfway
oh yep we're halfway through okay cool
yep very cool and Jade her class is shut
down because she's at the same point
yeah
but Dr John deloney Ken Coleman George
Campbell Eddie Cullen all have their
classes still open I think John starts
Monday Monday I heard yep so his is
coming there yep better get in there so
go fpu.com or ramsaysolutions.com and go
to the FPU pages and jump into the
Ramsey personality if you're watching on
YouTube there's a little QR code you got
to stick that back up there if you can
so people can get that QR code and jump
right straight to the page and yeah
fpu.com and take Ramsey take it with a
Ramsay personality if you'd like right
now they'll hold you accountable and
every dollar is included access to a
coach is included you do the whole
puppy and you're just you it's the
fastest way you can get control of this
stuff it's not easy we're never going to
make it easy because it's just not easy
it's hard it's life change but it is
worth it and this process works Abby is
in Dallas hi Abby welcome to the Ramsay
show
what's up
so my husband and I are in baby steps
four five and six uh nothing no debt
except for our mortgage and we're
wondering if it would be okay to pause
Investing For one maybe two months while
we cash flow an HVAC replacement
how much is the replacement
eleven thousand okay how much do you
guys make a year
um so our take-home pay per month is
usually about twenty thousand
um next month is probably gonna be about
sixteen thousand because I'm going to be
going for maternity leave so it's gonna
go down a little bit oh well
congratulations Abby so baby soon you
better you definitely need an air
conditioner
yeah that's pretty much where we're
coming from I'm actually three days
overdue right now oh my gosh and the ace
and the AC's out in Dallas is it out or
you just need a new one
so that's the thing it's not out
but every time it hits 90 or 100 here it
goes out we had it repaired about 10
times over the last 12 months and we
figure with a newborn and we have a
one-year-old as well we don't want I
mean it's Dallas it's gonna hit 90 or
100 in the next six weeks for sure and
we just want to get it taken care of
sure listen I completely agree that you
need an air conditioner with a brand new
baby and I completely understand when
you're two days overdue why this is a
big deal but you're going about it
completely the wrong way
I'm gonna love you enough to tell you
that you can fix this thing one more
time and take two months and save five
or six thousand dollars a month or three
months and save three thousand dollars a
month out of your twenty thousand dollar
sixteen thousand dollar income and you
can pay cash for this without stopping
your Investments
all right that's what I thought you were
gonna say I just wanted to double check
we all have Abby do you have an
emergency fund
yeah we do but we don't really consider
it I mean it doesn't qualify as an
emergency right we know yeah but I'm
just saying if it goes out there it lays
down and cannot be revived then you say
bring out the paddles clear boom and I
can't revive it right then use the
emergency room yeah now it's an
emergency or even Abby if you I mean
like again depending on another this is
your call but if you don't feel like and
like you're gonna need it sooner than
three months for some reason you could
take a couple thousand out of the
emergency fund with money you've saved
do it quick you know what I'm saying
like you can Shuffle things around uh
you have that emergency fund there so
because how big is your emergency fund
uh thirty thousand okay so if you took
11 out today you'd have 19 yeah it's not
an emergency so I wouldn't do that okay
but this is your fallback
yeah if something were to happen I'm
gonna let it I'm with Rachel I'm gonna
let it limp along my original suggestion
pile as much out of saving out of my
income as I can and if this thing gets
weird you have a brand new baby
it's it becomes an emergency if it
becomes an emergency then you use part
of the emergence let's say you'd say
five thousand dollars well you take six
out of the emergency fund two months
later you've put that back
right okay yeah so you don't need to be
pausing retirement for that you don't
have to be polishing retirement number
one but number two you don't need to be
worried as a mom of a newborn that we're
going to be in Jeopardy somehow we need
it and there's no anxiety around that
because you're going to fake you're
going to have heating and air it's just
a matter of how we go about it whether
we cash the emergency fund out or
whether we save all the way through or
whether we save part of the way through
and so by September you're going to have
a new Heating and Air
that's the way I would look at it if I
were you because I'm I'm just saying
this is super valid in your situation I
mean you're not in Minnesota you're in
Texas
yes it went out several times last
summer when I had a three-month-old baby
and that was super fun I was at 82
degrees in the house hours went out we
had no money Rachel was a brand new baby
we bought box fans those little cheap
butt fans down at Walmart because we
didn't have the money to fix it so we
survived but boy that was miserable and
I got to tell you it was 30 something
years ago and my wife my wife to this
day is really you know those are scars
that last so I'm I'm going to be on your
side the former me didn't do a good job
with that so I've been pissed if I was
Mom and that was you do what no I don't
know you would have been pissed yeah I
could just see Dave 30 years ago Sharon
suck it up get some fans an hour
midnight that's what we did absolutely
but she's not a whiner so she never
really had to suck it up she just like
yeah this is what we got to do but it
really really really is picking me off
yeah and I'm really going to remind you
for the next 35 years that we did this
yeah so but that that's fair that's fair
I mean I've yeah
but you can get those little box fan
things done they're like twelve dollars
just stop it they're like like two speed
right they're twelve dollars you know
but man Dallas is miserable in the heat
oh God the only thing worse being being
in Phoenix right
Phoenix is dry heat yeah yeah I like
sticking your head in an oven dry heat
yeah I love it when we go to Phoenix
they go it's 110 but it's dry heat and
I'm going there's an egg on the sidewalk
frying over there buddy okay but yeah
at least you can breathe in it Tennessee
in Dallas I love all of them they're
great both great cities both great
cities it's fun hey guys so the point
being you know when when you're broke
you don't have those options she's got
the emergency fund wouldn't it be
horrible oh God to be in that situation
have no money yeah because then she'd be
calling up going we need to borrow money
for a heating and air
and then I do remember when I finally
got to the other side of that and we
were at the
the first house we had over here in
Brentwood the one you grew up in and
that heating and air went out and I
remember I act it's weird I remember
this a long time ago it was in the 80s
but I remember the it was thirty four
hundred and eighteen dollars to put a
new unit on I still remember the number
because we had the money and you could
do it and I could just pull it out and
it was like this is the weirdest feeling
this is not an emergency it's an
inconvenience yep yep and now I've just
got to put 3 400 bucks back in there
because we're just you know because we
were literally the thing had laid down
yeah if we were frying in the house same
stuff but it was uh it would have been
you know six or eight years after the
bankruptcy now yeah and the Year we're
talking about with the box fans was the
bankruptcy year the year you were born
so wow imagine Rachel's little baby
crying screaming that's terrible it's
hot
y'all remember that this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five Lindsay is in
Colorado Springs hi Lindsay welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey what's up
so my husband and I are looking for your
guidance related to the costs that we're
paying to our financial advisor for
managing our growing retirement
portfolio how much are you paying to
find out
um well we're we've we've had a lot of
conversations related to this um so
we're at 0.87
yearly but when we look at the impact of
a growing portfolio and compounding
interest we're not we're wanting to make
sure that we're being good stewards and
that there's value for those fees that's
a normal managed fund uh or managed
amount for a million dollar account
so if it grows above a million dollars
do you end up with I mean it should be
it should be discipline it should be
going down
um I mean if you want to shop it around
but they're not ripping you off that's
that's a fairly standard yeah way
managed accounts are how almost all
Brokers are handling it now they used to
sell mutual funds on commission
and and now they just plump them in
there and manage the whole thing on a
managed account uh I would say 90
something percent of our smart investor
Pros use that exact system
uh now it could it be that you know
what's the size of your portfolio
million you said
oh it's only 500 000 right now oh you're
fine I have 20 working years and so we
were just looking at you know what would
Dave say you've obviously got you know a
multi-million dollar portfolio like are
we doing the best we should do we get
the value is there you know do you want
to have that managed or is there a
better way to do it yeah most uh uh most
of our Ramsay personalities most of the
people in the building are doing that
with one of our Smart Vista Pros exactly
that way my personal portfolio was set
up before that stuff came on and it's
old school and so and I don't ever buy
or sell I just buy and hold so there's
not a lot of management to it so I've
never moved it personally into that but
it's not because it's a rip-off it's not
because we hate it it's not that at all
it's just mine was Antiquated and I just
there's no point in doing it because I
don't do anything with it it just sits
there so but I I think that you know
again
the most the folks in this building a
George camel I suspect the Rachel Cruz I
don't know those kinds of folks are
they're paying a managed fee with one of
our smart investor pros and it's
probably right at about that same amount
now it is fair for you to ask what the
flip they're doing to earn that
you know it's fair to go okay if if you
are you just sitting here looking at it
and it just not I mean what are we
getting for our one percent you know
that's a fair question it's not like you
and I don't suggest you do a bunch of
buying and selling so you know I don't
want there to I I really big on just
buying and keeping it unless there's a
real reason to get out of the fund when
Lindsay the the person managing it for
you guys just do they sit down and look
at your entire Financial picture at all
like is there or is it just specifically
just investing because our smart
investor Pro I mean we sit down we look
at basically everything which is just so
helpful like that's one reason I love
having somebody we sit down every
January and it's everything from
investing to looking at kids college to
even giving purposes of stuff that they
like they just know that world some
estate planning yeah they just I mean in
your case actually your guy called out a
really good Capital thing capital gains
thing on a piece of real estate yeah we
had our our house when we moved we kept
it for a rental but then we were going
to sell it and it was a capital gains
thing so yeah he just like gave us
information and I was like oh yeah
that's right okay so it's just having
somebody in your corner so you don't
have that but you have but you have
estate planning with attorney I mean all
that stuff but I'm saying you have you
have people in your corner well I've got
him in my corner I mean I just don't pay
him a monthly fee yeah I mean I'll pay
him an annual fee because I bought the
funds and paid the commissions up front
shares right they're called and so uh
and I've already paid the deal and it's
just sitting there and again I haven't
sold a mutual fund in probably 20 years
I just buy them
you know I just died Mike I have no
activity on my account at all except
purchases so it's just not a thing so
but I think it's a great conversation
and I would sit down I will tell you
that the vast majority of quality uh
financial planner types broker types and
financial advice people managing helping
you with your retirement accounts those
kinds of things are set up on exactly
that plan there's a few people that
still do only a shares a lot of people
will only do that plan now because of
liability that they take on under the
federal erisa rules and so forth if they
don't do that plan but uh but I I it is
a great conversation to have and say why
are you worth one percent why would I
not just buy this on my own and not give
you 0.87 R1 or whatever it is right but
but you're not out of line you're not
getting ripped off I wouldn't be
panicking about it but you're very wise
to start out to be always asking these
questions
a you need to understand your
Investments and B you don't need to
understand anything you're being charged
and what are you getting for what you're
being charged I think those are
wonderful now I will tell you this
everybody out there not not you Lindsay
because I don't think that's going on
with you but
there again
there's these all there's these little
nuanced pieces of research studies that
are done the people that do not have a
broker like that in their corner are
are unbelievably more likely to pull
their money out every time there's bad
news
and to put polar money at exactly the
wrong time and buy at exactly the wrong
time trying to time the market so if you
never pull your money out it's worth
0.87 just to keep you from jumping off
the cliff just to talk you off the ledge
just to talk you off the ledge because
you're having a broker in your corner
goes don't do that here's the historical
data here's what happens you know every
year following a two-year downturn
except one since the 1930s we've seen a
huge uptick we've had two down years
we're going to see a huge uptick
historically coming up most people don't
know that but if you've studied the
charts and you know what the mutual fund
returns are you know the stock market
returns are you know that and you're a
broker and you're advising people you
can talk them off the ledge and go
you're getting ready to get out at
exactly the wrong time I know it's been
flat I know it's been sucky we've you
know we're in an inflationary Biden
economy it's horrible out there life's
not good I get that but just hang on the
Sun is going to come up tomorrow and
they talk you off that ledge and you're
getting ready to bail at exactly the
wrong time yep and and so that that
having that broker in your corner to
bounce stuff off of or occasionally
bring yourself motion out of it yeah
yeah bring you a different idea or a
different way of looking at something
not constantly buying and selling the
account though now that you we don't
want to do that but just to just to have
somebody there that's walking with you
in the you know got your best interest
at heart because they make money only
when you do
um and and you know that that's if the
thing if the whole thing goes down in
value they make less so that that's not
a bad way to incentivize them but you
know it's it is a great thing back to
her original point to ask and understand
always know why you're being charged and
what you're getting for what you're
being charged
love it
good stuff so yeah the um being
Diversified spreading your portions to
seven yes to eight not having all your
money in one stock not buying and
selling hold on no one gets hurt on a
roller coaster except those that jump
off in the middle of the ride having
someone in your corner like a smart
investor Pro to teach you to meet with
you to review your stuff uh making sure
and here's the key always have somebody
with a heart of a teacher always have
someone that's where you know what's
going on yeah because there are I mean
like any industry
in every industry there's good people
and there's bad people and so you're
gonna feel like oh I don't feel right
with this person I don't really like
them I don't you know if you get that
feeling then don't use them so right and
I feel like that sometimes this industry
can be slime like I feel like The
Stereotype sometimes it's like oh I
don't want to use someone because I
don't want to pay them and they're going
to try to they're going to try to get me
like there's plenty of good ones yes yes
more good ones than bad ones yes but if
they got the heart of a Salesman you'll
feel like you need a shower after you
met with them right and so no that's not
you're looking for someone with the
heart of a teacher someone to walk you
through teach you teach you and you'll
know they have the heart of a teacher if
you learn something every time you meet
with them
you should know something more than you
knew before every time you meet with
them they're teacher then and they're
wanting you to understand your own stuff
because you're responsible for it not
them my man lost all my money no you
lost all your money because you trusted
a goober
it's your fault
you didn't understand what was going on
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show for we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author host co-host of
the smart money happy hour exceedingly
popular podcast on Ramsay networks with
George Campbell be sure you check it out
she's my co-host today the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Sarah's in Hartford Connecticut
hi Sarah welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi Rachel thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so I'm hoping you can settle a
disagreement between me and my husband
I'm 26 he's 30. we have a household
income of around 140 000
um our net worth is 250
um thousand we've never um carried that
except for our mortgage the problem is
that I've been feeling super
underutilized and unfulfilled at work
and have asked for more work more
projects and kind of concluded that this
field may just not be for me
um so I've dreamed of going to law
school so it would be part time and in
the evening but my husband thinks that
giving up the stability and the growth
trajectory of our current situation to
cash flow it would set us back greatly
and is just not worth it
and I'm just looking for insight on that
or what you think
uh what do you do now Sarah what kind of
line what kind of field are you working
in
I'm a public librarian
okay
uh and how much would it take for you to
get a law degree have you priced
anything out
yep it would be 88 000 over four years
since I'd be doing it part-time
okay see okay so 22 a year
it's a cash flowing
um what are you making now as a
librarian
um how much of that 140 is yours 55 65
for my full-time
um with projected increases of nine
percent over the next two years okay
okay
this is not the math of his
uh proposal or his concern is not
logical
unless he believes you're not going to
use the law degree
do you think he thinks you're not going
to follow through and be a lawyer
like I mean if you if you have two kids
or you're going to quit and go home
no I think he probably thinks that the
money wouldn't be so much more
considering like it's probably go up to
90 in the next few years
well over the scope of your life a
lawyer makes more than a librarian hello
that's not hard right
that's kind of yeah of course of course
it's worth 88 000.
the return on investment of 88 000 if
you work as a lawyer the rest of your
life and do a decent to a really really
good job you should make six figures
not 90. and uh now I mean you can
there's plenty of lawyers don't make any
money where they're horrible lawyers and
they don't manage to practice well and
they don't you know they manage their
career favor or they're in the public
sector I mean yeah or they stay and they
work for the state or something you know
but you know you you can you can get a
law degree and not maximize it but and
that's such a broad
um field anyway Sarah do you have do you
do you have a do you have a passion
about a specific type of law that you're
like I really yeah want to do that or is
it kind of just this broad like law
school just sounds great
yeah it would be human rights that's
kind of what I've always wanted to go
into I've applied for law librarian
positions and I've gotten pretty far so
I've kind of been close to that but it's
just hasn't worked out yeah my first my
first reaction when I hear that category
is you're going to do a lot of pro bono
work and you're not going to make any
money sounds more like a crusader than a
lawyer
did I miss something
no no I think which is not wrong
that doesn't make you a bad person it
makes you excellent but it does it does
justify your husband's position
yeah because if you go in that type of
law and you're you know you're working
on crusades all the time which are great
I mean human rights I can't think of
anything better but uh uh you know
you're protecting other people you're
using your knowledge and your your the
tools in your belt to fight for the uh
injustices in the world that's wonderful
but but you know I unless I'm missing
something I don't think that's a big
paying side of the law
and then then he starts to be right
yeah but unless you guys decided
as well that yeah we're gonna sacrifice
our lifestyle and we're gonna cash flow
this obviously we'd say that regardless
um but in what you're wanting to do with
your life yeah he says it's not worth it
money was is what he said I know but
then a pardon me is like yeah but I mean
if you can pay for it
and that's what you want to do that's
your line of work I mean unless you can
get about that same passion a different
door than just having a law degree but I
just I I mean I've you know we work with
a lot of non-profits and I can think of
two examples right now where people have
traveled internationally out of you know
uh you know persecuting sex traffickers
and they're and they're putting laws in
place prosecute thank you yeah we should
persecute them first but prosecuted All
the Above All the Above no but but I'm
saying like there's such good work in
that and a part of me is like not mad if
you guys decide hey I'm in a casual
degree to be able to use I'm okay with
that yeah but then you know but the way
you presented this it was more like he
wasn't supporting his wife's dream
uh and and all he's challenging is the
financials on the dream and so that's so
it comes back to a values question yeah
it comes down to do you guys want to
spend the money for a break even because
you want to be in this field yeah yeah
that's fine or is there another way to
go in that field if you want to practice
it plays a lot more
if you want to practice a uh a higher
compensated type of law
with your law degree then uh it becomes
a no-brainer financially for you to go
get the law degree okay but yeah this is
a really good healthy discussion for you
guys to have because what you're you
know if he comes to agreement on this
he's agreeing to support your passions
in spite of the math
and that that's what he's doing and and
all he's saying right now is the math
doesn't work
and but if if you want to do it in spite
of the math I I I'm okay with that yeah
that that's okay and again Sarah I would
really
I would uh I would just challenge you to
say hey what type of human rights am I
do I feel called to do I feel like
pulled to and go and work with people in
that sector I mean like I I would I
would get in there and just like
experience all of it because sometimes
like any any job any career any passion
anything it can seem one way right kind
of glamorous and then once you get in
there you're like oh man I don't know if
if this is what I want to do for you
yeah right I might take my vacation time
and intern in a human rights law firm
that's spending their time on on these
causes and for the summer and see how it
feels yeah yeah that would be a Ken
Coleman type of a suggestion Rachel just
made and that's a good one or a Rachel
crew suggestion that Rachel Cruz just
made oh well
where's that too yeah Ken Coleman in my
head
I didn't say quick I did say persecuting
myself prosecute so quick get him out
yeah you're persecuted right now
I did
man I had such a good point I screwed up
words words are hard
that's okay I'll mess up in mixed
metaphors that's just for family trait
it's a family trait this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is with
me as a co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our question of the day comes from
neighborly the Ramsay show question of
the day is sponsored by your hub for
Home Services take your homes efficiency
and style to the next level with
convenient solutions from shelf Genie
window Genie glass doctor and Mr
Appliance
visit neighborly.com and you can
schedule all these different kinds of
Home Services and professionals they'll
help you out today's question comes from
Catherine in Wisconsin what do you
usually use as a guideline for a buffer
in your checking account is this
different from the miscellaneous line
item on the budgets uh yes that is
different so having a zero-based budget
does not mean a zero balance in your
checking account so God keep uh keep a
buffer there because stuff is going to
come up and you just want to be able to
make sure that you're not you know
dipping into the red and you're checking
and getting hit with those fees and
penalties and everything so
um yeah to having just a buffer we don't
really give a specific dollar amount or
percentage it's really going to depend
on your income and where you feel
comfortable but just making sure yeah
you don't go in the red but then your
miscellaneous category is a diff that's
in your budget with the income that you
have to be able to say hey stuff is
going to come up realistically and when
things do come up that we didn't plan
for it doesn't completely whack out our
budget it right we still have a
zero-based budget so that miscellaneous
category is very crucial because
stuff always comes up that you just
don't even think about yeah
miscellaneous is completely separate as
Rachel said and I would say your buffer
in your checking needs to be well under
a thousand unless you're above baby step
three
if you're getting out of debt and
building your emergency fund any money
that approaches a thousand dollars ought
to be in savings towards are in your
debt you know moving on you don't need a
like a two thousand dollar buffer in
your savings in your checking account
while you're trying to get out of debt
so keep it under a grand until you're
out at north of baby step three
um you know somewhere maybe I you again
based on your income and what's going on
how much money is flowing through the
account what a mistake would look like
those kinds of things but it does not
mean zero-based Budget means every
dollar that is coming in has an
assignment
and that's of your income not every
dollar in your checking account there
are two different things Kim is in Los
Angeles hi Kim how are you
hi I'm very blessed thank you how are
you better than I deserve what's up
well thank you for taking my call
um my husband and I have started this a
lot later than we thought we would or
should we've been getting the last 20
years of our life we've kind of been
scraping by on God's grace and finally
in this last year we are on two incomes
um and then now that we're starting this
we find ourselves I guess between baby
steps maybe we can say
um so the question is uh can we cash out
my 401k to get our house to what we feel
we need it to be for our growing family
um and then restart our long-term
Investments how old are you since we
can't move
um 43.
okay well if you did that you would get
a 10 penalty
and your tax rate
and uh what's your household income
about 135 five okay and so that just
started it's about a 40 we'll go to the
government of everything you take out
and so that's kind of like saying Dave I
want to borrow money at 40 interest to
fix up my house
I'd be dumb
okay follow that
you wouldn't you wouldn't borrow money
at 40 would you
no no I hope not okay you're not that
girl I know you're not Jim what baby
steps are you guys when you said I'm in
between what what are those
um well we have like 15 000 and saving
yet I have about 10 000 with debt but
then we have the 401K about 50 000 there
okay well you're not doing the baby
steps you're doing your plan
okay yeah we just started when I was
looking I was trying to figure out what
to do first ah okay and how much will
the home repairs be
about the 50. okay and you said you're
uh so you don't have enough anyway even
if you want to do it because you got the
penalties and the interest
um right penalties and taxes so uh
anyway but the um so fifty thousand
worth of repairs and you've got uh
fifteen thousand savings and you've got
how much in debt
okay and minus 10 okay and you you said
your household was 130.
okay all right all right what are the
nature of the repairs
um I have
um
a boy girl siblings that are sharing a
room right now the older the boy is 13
and the little one's four and I want to
um I'm gonna put up a room like separate
a different room so that they can have
two separate rooms and then we also
don't have central air or Heating
okay and then we also don't have our
house didn't come with a garage so we
need some sort of storage okay I I can
tell you what Sharon and I did when we
were at your stage
we sold our house and rented
oh
and um that got us that got us out of
debt and
um we rented for two years and we
actually hated the rental house
my wife really hated it but um but but
it it gave us more space and in our case
it was a school district thing got us
into the right school district and saved
us a bunch of money that way in your
case it might just give you a bedroom
and a garage
and uh and and you're debt free and you
build your emergency fund and then you
start saving up to repurchase a home
that does fit later because I think this
house might be left over from a
different stage of your life
yeah it was yeah like we have a 2.9
interest right now oh well
oh well doesn't matter you you don't
have 50 you don't have fifty thousand
dollars and you got a situation that's
untenable for your family
right so I I honestly speaking of moving
but it's just the house are so big right
now which is we can't afford to move so
yeah I mean you're in Los Angeles we
didn't even think of that yeah yeah I I
I might do that and here's what I want
to do I want to put the two of you
through Financial Peace University so
you can learn the baby steps and do this
so baby step one's a thousand dollars we
want you to do that first you got that
saved two is debt free but other than
the Home Three is to build an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
so what that would lead us to do if you
were following that would be to take
enough out of your 15 000 pay off your
ten thousand dollars in debt today
you're debt free but the house leaves
you five thousand and then you build
that emergency fund up from five to
three to six months of expenses you're
not putting anything into retirement
while you're doing that and and what I
was reaching for early in the call was
uh on the fifty thousand if you do want
to stay it's uh the way we've always
worked it at our house and we teach
people to work it is it's not enough
it's not a no it's a not yet
we can't do it today but we could do it
making 130 000. after we do these other
steps we could do it out there it might
be three years and even logistically Kim
you said that there is there another
room in the house
uh it was it's like a living room that
we were gonna separate okay okay I got
you so it would take some yeah but it's
not a fifty thousand dollar renovation
it doesn't have to be you're that's a
big number to put up a wall
yeah we were just figuring while we're
doing that we'll do the honesty also let
you know yeah we'll do that yeah so even
look at doing one at a time and that may
even be yeah just you know that may even
take some even if you guys don't want to
move right maybe moving moving is an
option or just hey how long would this
take us to cash flow this yeah
um what's the priority for me it's for
me it's probably the bedroom and the
number two is HVAC and number three
whatever else you had mentioned yet
that's in the 50k because you still
haven't gotten the 50k with HVAC in a
bedroom
oh there it is okay that one's way down
the list all right so maybe it's a
storage unit yeah for a little bit or
maybe we sell some or sell stuff that
kind of I mean you just got to begin to
work this through but yeah I'm hate to
disappoint you but that 50k is really
not accessible uh without giving up 40
of it so I wouldn't do that under any
circumstances only the only
circumstances to avoid a bankruptcy or
foreclosure and that's not really on
your situation you're just tired of
fighting this and not winning so hang on
Austin's going to pick up we're going to
put you through Financial Peace
University so you can learn how to do
this stuff you and your husband together
do it it's going to change everything
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
for those of you listening live or close
to live
tomorrow would be Thursday the 18th we
will
be doing some stuff with Fox tomorrow
I'll be on the fox and friends in the
morning and the seven o'clock hour
central time uh and Rachel's leaving uh
and Dr John deloney and Ken Coleman Jade
and Jade warshaw our flight leaving
first thing in the morning fly up and
they're doing a town hall with Fox
Business at noon Central Time uh taking
questions from the audience uh about
inflation about debt credit card debt
student loan debt all the things that
are going on out there and so the three
of them will be part of that town hall
at noon Central Time on Fox Business
Thursday the 18th for those of you
listening live is tomorrow live or
tomorrow so hey thanks for joining us
Charles is with us Charles is in Phoenix
Arizona hi Charles how are you
so I'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up I was calling because
I'm having a bit of trouble over the
last two years my question is how can I
work towards budgeting with my wife
we've been married for two years I was
working on the baby steps before
marriage we got married and anything
Dave Ramsey or Dave Ramsey personality
my wife despises not to just reality of
it and
um anything anytime I bring up the
budget or talking through the budget or
sticking to the budget
um it's like scratching Nails on a
chalkboard to her so since since Rachel
and I are so lovable if she despises us
that would be your fault
for the record she didn't like you
before she married me
well then you got yourself into this I
don't think I can help you
I'm nicer Charles maybe she'll like me
so tomorrow follow me on Instagram now
you're a Ramsey personality he already
said there we go she just may lump me in
with you you know we're two separate
people oh wow so maybe she would like a
female perspective I don't know okay
I've had lots of women say so okay try
that on board because of Rachel it's
really not us that she doesn't like us
she never met us
um so we're not offended by that but
there's something that we are asking are
suggesting that she do that she's
opposed to and that would be controlling
her spending or that would be putting up
with you being a control freak and
telling her what to do all the time or
that would be there's something that she
Associates us with
that's negative because being a grown-up
and telling your money what to do is not
something people generally oppose
yeah it's been opposed to me it's the
the common phrase is I'm not living like
I'm broke well okay there's the
objection
yeah there's the objection okay so she
Associates us with uh extreme frugality
to a ridiculous level with no point
yeah and that's not a it's not actually
what we teach obviously we teach Extreme
frugality for a short period of time so
that you can live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else it's the later part that she
hasn't gotten or doesn't believe that
can happen or doesn't believe it can
happen okay so
um obviously you're gonna have to take a
different approach than you've taken
and if you've turned us into a cuss word
you can never mention us again
so I think you guys need marriage
counseling
okay um then you're probably not then
you're probably not gonna make it
because if she says you're not worth
our relationship is not worth
working on
she's made she's giving you a really
loud statement
I understand what's uh Charles what's
her what what does she oppose that that
factor right that you marriage
counseling what's what is her opposition
towards that what does she say
it's not really an opposition more of a
I don't get a straightforward opposition
it's more of a
kind of a Dodge of the question or the
topic I don't I'm not a my opinion is
maybe she doesn't feel that she needs it
or that we need it but I've brought it
up several times I myself
um I'm all in favor of counseling and
and therapy and help I myself started
going to one or a therapist earlier this
year just to improve myself see if I can
be a better husband to my wife but a
father to our kids I think I think your
therapist needs to guide you through
these relationship issues I don't think
we're qualified
okay because I don't think this is about
a budget and I don't think this is about
Ramsay personalities or Dave Ramsey I
think I think this is about she's been
hurt she's scared she's angry
um she didn't trust there's a lot going
on here that I don't even know what it
is
um and apparently you don't either at
this stage and that's what you guys have
got to work on you've got to get to
where you uh love each other and and
will do anything for each other to serve
each other and have a great future
together and right now everything that
comes up to better your life you get a
big Shield that comes up and that's
based on fear or based on anger yeah
there's other stuff going on there's
other stuff going on there and it's not
it's not us I mean it's not it's not a
there's not we're not the problem and so
we're also not the solution
that's what it comes down to so I'm
sorry you're facing that man it's a hard
thing to go through especially in a
two-year-old marriage I mean it's just
awful it's just not it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be better than this you
know but yeah I think your therapist
needs to give you
um some very specific things to draw
out and and you know because this is not
a sustainable relationship the way it's
operating
you're not going to be 40 years from
today still married doing it this way
I mean because people finally they just
get enough and they're not going to
they're not alone she's going to get
enough she's going to run out with her
hair on fire or vice versa so you have
to be growing and working together or
you can't stay together in a culture
where nobody stays together I've been
married 41 years Sharon says we had 30
years of good marriage
uh actually she used to say that when it
was 37 there's about about seven years
in there you know and yeah it's bad the
fur the first years were rough and uh
but yeah it's and it was mostly on me so
in that case I don't know if this is on
you I don't know if you're being
controlling and you're not you don't
sound like it in this call but it
doesn't mean you're not
and the positive spin Charles is if if
you guys get to that place I think
there's always the beauty in your two
years in which means the habits and what
you guys can create as a foundation of
your marriage can be a real yeah I mean
you guys may just be doing this head
Collision that some people don't
experience so 10 years down the road
you're doing it two years uh but I hope
that it I hope that it works out and
that you guys can see yourselves as a
team and again like you said just
continuing to grow
and who you are as people
um and stuff yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
bet that there's a lot of stuff going on
in her so and she may not even know
that's the other thing that's what's
hard that's right that's what a good
therapist would do I really pray she
would go because they're the ones that
can unpeel those layers and so much of
the unconscious that we live that comes
out in these ways Right comes out that
oh I don't want to I don't want to do I
don't want to budget oh don't control my
money I don't want to work on myself
like there's there's a reason she's
dodging off if you say don't say
Financial Peace don't say Dave Ramsey
Rachel cruise to me ever if you're out
there and you you have a spouse saying
that then it's your fault because you've
used us as a weapon
and we're not a weapon we're teachers
and so you used us to try to control
them and they don't want to be
controlled so instead of persuading you
tried to use a club
and that's not how marriage and how
relationships work and so yeah if if I
if we have become a cuss word in your
marriage that's your fault because we
didn't do anything to become a cuss word
except try to help you and we're not
offended by that it's not we're not
there's no defensiveness at all in that
it's just funny and but but and it makes
great jokes and those are all fun we can
have we can we can do all that stuff but
the bottom line is is that you know
you're being too stinking controlling or
you're using this as a club instead of
you know hey I learned this great new
thing to get out of debt we're going to
sell your car honey you know
Dave Ramsey said you know that that was
dumber than a rock it didn't work this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
s
our scripture of the day Proverbs 3 5
and 6 trust in the Lord with all your
heart and do not lean on your own
understanding in all your ways
acknowledge Him and He will make your
paths straight
Annie Downs Rachel's friend says if you
will go where you've never gone before
you will see God like you've never seen
him before it sounds very NES she was
over last night's well there you go
having dinner hanging out with famous
hanging out with famous people no well
but she is she's my only famous friend
no I don't hang out with famous people
just everyone be clear not true not true
I know all of them yeah there we go I
ain't no paying off debt is smart saving
and investing is smart protecting your
finances playing defensive smart there
are 10 kinds of insurance coverage you
might need based on what your life looks
like today and we've built a tool called
coverage checkup to show you which types
you need to add drop or adjust you can
check it out it's free the coverage
checkup at ramseysolutions.com checkup
ramseysolutions.com checkup Graham is in
Seattle hey Graham welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Grant or hey Dave and Rachel it's an
honor to speak to you both you too sir
what's up
so um after struggling for about a year
or two to get pregnant my wife and I are
expecting quintuplets
so we have five babies on the way and um
you know we we consider them a blessing
uh we are super excited about them that
doesn't mean we're not a little bit
stressed about it and um I'm stressed
already babies how far along is she
Graham
uh Friday is 25 weeks wow oh my goodness
how's she feeling
she's finally starting to eat solid food
so that's a very good thing I'm guessing
I'm guessing you guys are doing all
kinds of things to uh extend the
pregnancy as long as possible Right like
bed rest or whatever all that kind of
stuff
she's on bed rest yet but we actually
did we're temporarily relocated to the
Phoenix area I'm the world's best
quintuplet doctors here yeah so his his
goal is to get her to 34 weeks yeah
because averages around two weeks until
yeah we kind of dropped everything in
our lives to focus on this and give
these babies the best shot absolutely
yeah that's that's uh that's a lot of
wisdom well done wow what an adventure
yeah yeah it is I'm not sure we have
anything to add to this but um anyway
how can we help
well you know I think
just my immediate question would be so
we are
um I guess we're on technically baby
step four but we're not really investing
right now we don't have any debt
um we have about 40 000 in a bank
account saved up yeah and um
in terms of my work I am a freelancer so
my work is really all over the place
that's kind of the one one of the major
things I do struggle with
um I found success with it and I'm happy
about it but it's definitely more random
um but I do have income coming in still
which I'm really thankful for and so I
think my immediate question for you guys
would just be is there anything unique
that you would do you know over the next
year
um in this situation we have no other
kids
I would put everything on pause until
you get this situation stabilized
okay and that's gonna you know that's
gonna be well into Year One
okay no I'm not I mean I don't I don't
have any insight under the medical
stability uh but you've got all kinds of
potential things there you've got to get
all the medical things stabilized but
then you've also got to get just you
know lifestyle just your house
stabilized five beds five whatever right
five million diapers I mean it's like
right so you know there you just got to
get a rhythm to this this is this is
five times as much so
um
yeah I mean I I think there's a whole
lot of things you're going to learn
about uh creating sanity out of this in
the first year
does that make any sense
it does and I as big a pile of cash as
you can have and don't worry about
investing don't worry about the baby
steps just push pause just a big
stinking pile of cash because that
that's one less thing to worry about in
the middle of all this other uh this
adventure that you're on
yeah
now I don't want you using this to say
oh we can never invest the rest of our
lives that's not what I'm saying but I
am saying let's get this to get the
rhythm of the medical condition of the
kids the rhythm of how the household
operates processes systems you all use
to feed five clean five whatever you get
five to sleep all that kind of you know
there's a process you're going to do
that you're going to learn from other
people and develop in this that's
um that's gonna take a lot of your
bandwidth yeah and honestly you guys I
mean I would I would predict yeah even
just the mental capacity to even have to
think about money and stuff like don't
even let don't worry more about it right
like you have you have money in the bank
and don't go in debt don't and don't
invest yep just don't let
um for a year
because you guys are it's gonna be yeah
there's me
no yeah more important stuff going on I
feel like of like yeah so just knowing
that that money is there there's cash
available if you need it
um but how to the way I look at it is
this I mean this is a type of investment
in the sense that you're investing in
the kids you're investing in the
stability of your family in getting this
into a sustainable rhythm
you know getting getting everything on
on a you know on a plane that it has a
has a a reasonable level of uh of
predictability so then you can start to
say okay now we can invest now I can
work this much I can create this much
income as a freelancer we can invest
this much well you guys have help Graham
family and
that's that's kind of the other
interesting part so we we live about
actually an hour and a half north of
Seattle or in the northwest corner and
that's the part of the country my wife
is from however her family has kind of
migrated out of the area
um we will be living in her in-laws
house just to kind of get through this
first year they're like half and living
in her in-laws house
sorry my in-law's house okay it's
already happened
yeah so
that's good so you're going to be yeah
living with family daring well listen
um we have a really good Church
community back there that we know we're
going to do a lot of help from my
family's in Tennessee though so that's
kind of the I I feel like the elephant
in the room is maybe going moving to
Tennessee long term just the cost of
living is so much better but yeah again
I think I think that's a choice you make
after the year after you get the year
behind you
gotcha yeah because the labor the
delivery as you know it's a very
specialized thing you've made a
specialized choice to move because of
that and and there's just so much going
on there and then the the the the
setting up of of I mean I don't know
what else to call it other than systems
the operations of this oh no it'll be a
station that is just it'll be a
well-oiled machine oh wow yeah you got
to get it dialed in and it's a thing so
wow so I'm so happy for you yeah that's
so exciting Graham so happy let us know
how it turns out that's just amazing
yeah so great I want to hear the rest of
the story as they say as Paul Harvey
used to say yeah oh Miracles
um yeah as a sidebar for the rest of you
listening I want to make real sure that
no one misunderstood what I was saying I
am not saying large families can't do
our stuff I'm saying for a period of
time they are facing a very unique
situation large families do our stuff
all the time there are also people that
have large families that whine to no end
that they can't do our stuff because
they have of a large family and that we
just don't understand bull you can use
common sense even if you have a large
family you can live on less than you
make and invest even if you have a large
family you can stay out of debt even if
you have a large family as a matter of
fact you especially need to if you have
a large family do all of those things
and we have lots of people pull up in
the uh in the Sprinter and nine kids get
out and they come in here and visit us
all the time and do their debt free
screams and then they go yeah I read
those articles that Dave Ramsey doesn't
know about large families maybe maybe
and we're we're pro Ramsey and we're a
large family you know they do it all the
time so I hear it all the time so that's
not what we're saying we're seriously if
you're bringing home five newborn babies
that you're okay for a short period of
time you're gonna have to put everything
on hold and get your life yes in the in
the uh sane column from the insane
column yeah yeah wow what a wonderful
thing congratulations wow
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]